[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream number
59 i am as always sitting with dr
heather heing
and we are going to discuss all sorts of
interesting things today some of them a
holdover from the last
episode which uh very well received and
uh we did not get to everything so we
didn't and we're not going to get to
everything we planned last week this
week
either um but we do we're going to start
with a few corrections
right and uh then talk about some of
what the cdc
is suggesting with regard to vaccine
deployment
speak a little bit to a recent paper in
the new england journal of medicine with
regard to
declaration of sex on birth certificates
you've got some things to say about
journalism and interface with markets
and then we want to finish off by
talking about the
time of year that we're in right now
with regard to the solstice
hanukkah just ending christmas coming up
in less than a week or a week
week from yesterday and we'll end with a
short um seasonally appropriate reading
all right so it sounds like there's a
lot going on cosmically and
cosmologically and in every other way
and we just have to
you know dive in there is actually
something going on cosmologically what
is it uh
jupiter boy i can't remember uh jupiter
and saturn
are going to appear to be at their
closest
that they have for something more than
800 years within a few days of now i'm
doing all this off the top of my head i
don't remember exactly what the
what the date is and what the amount of
time it's been since they have appeared
this close in the sky
i i know nothing about this have not
read anything but i can say that i think
i felt that
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah all right
um so sure yeah we got uh i mean i was
thinking much more locally at the uh
at the cosmological level just the um
the whole solsticeness of it but uh but
we'll get there
ah yes yes i don't know does um
yeah i guess the solstice is inherently
a more local phenomenon than the fact
that
from earth jupiter and saturn are about
to appear to be as close as they
have in hundreds of years yeah they're
kind of equally local
actually those observations those those
one of them is a
reliably recurring astronomical reality
and one of them but the risk of creating
more corrections for the next livestream
am i in the ballpark to say that we
are closer to the sun than we are we are
certainly going to be closer to
the sun than we are to jupiter on
average but are we closer to the sun
than we are to jupiter at our closest in
which case it would be fair to say that
our
solstice was right a good bit and i this
is this was the math i was trying to do
in my head and i just don't i'm not
i think so but i don't know and i'm sure
we'll hear all right yes
we're gonna find out as we always do as
we always do
all right so uh we spent most of last
time talking about
uh the new vaccines that are now being
deployed
and uh we have two um i think of the
general scheme of things pretty minor
corrections to make
um one of which is the subject of a
ligand which most people will have
um heard me say and then just uh just
blown off because it's a
yet another technical term that most
people have no familiarity with
um so there are two definitions and i
said as a throwaway line the chemistry
definition rather than molecular biology
definition
the molecular biology definition being
something like
something that binds to a receptor
something that has a reversible
and that is reversible and um i will say
i just wanted to
you know this but um back when i taught
with my favorite molecular biologist and
i taught with him what three times i
guess
um i he you know he always used this
word
and every single time i said to him i
i'm not
the definition that you're using is not
sticking for me
and ultimately we we agreed um
in part because of the sort of the
milieu in which we were in where i was
teaching phylogenetic systematics that
is to say macroevolution how it is that
we make claims about deep history
and what those claims are and also
comparative anatomy and he was teaching
genetics and molecular biology and
developmental biology and so these these
all these fields sort of colliding
in a i thought mostly really effective
way in this program
um in my language of phylogenetic
systematics
i came to understand ligand is the sort
of junk term it's like this category
that isn't a single
thing it certainly doesn't have a single
history um
it's it's kind of vague and it
can mean different things even within
molecular biology depending on
exactly what the context is so you know
it's a molecule or something's an atom
that binds to another thing it's always
an organic molecule it binds to
often it's a protein but not always and
i think
it's always reversible although i'm not
even sure it's always used that way i
think i think it has to be
to meet the definition i i think so but
you know it's just
it's what's one rabbit hole after
another so i don't know i sort of see it
as a natural category the idea is
yeah you have a bunch of things that uh
react in some way so basically you've
got an informational system
built in physical space as i guess they
all have to be
but the idea is the trigger for the
thing that reacts
is the ligand and it's not about what it
is it's about the fact that it's a
trigger
and so in some ways maybe you know it's
exactly as real category as
receptor right so ligand and receptor
you know go together
it's lock and key and that's not exactly
the right analogy but it's one that's
been made lots of times
and um it is not the kind of category
like
mammal right right it's the kind of
category like
flight and because we were playing
around
you know in when when i was first and
repeatedly exposed to this term
we were so playing around in an
epistemological space of like what
you know what is the nature of
similarity what makes the what makes a
thing the same
under what circumstances is a wing a
wing for most recent common ancestor as
opposed to a wing
because these two organisms a dragonfly
and a swan
their ancestors distinctly and
convergently
arrived at a similar solution to a
similar ecological problem
and you can you know you can get into
severe naval gazing you know
at the point you're talking about uh a
samara right is that a wing
which right probably requires something
being the thing on
the seed this has evolved many times but
you're if you're familiar with it you're
probably familiar with it from a maple
a maple seed helicopters down and when
it falls off the tree because of this
wing
a samara so is that wing the same thing
as a bird swing same thing as a batsuing
insect swing etc but on the other hand
if you don't
decide the definition has to be you have
to perfectly solve a demarcation
problem in order to be valid we use
these things
all the time right warm blooded isn't
one thing virus isn't one thing
um you know so you know tree vine
whatever your category true these things
are
uh multiply evolved and that doesn't
mean that
um the fact of the category isn't useful
yeah so i mean i guess for um for people
who watching even those who have no
interest
in the deep dive into sort of what what
jargon means what
there are within different ways of
trying to understand the universe going
to be different
categories of names for things which can
be
very different right so you know it
seems like ligand and receptor are both
you know both both exist as categories
outside of human naming of them
but if a molecule that has been a ligand
is found in some other context in which
it acts in a different way and does not
operate
such that it slots into a receptor and
can and can reverse that action
it is no longer a ligand so that's
that's one true thing
and then another true thing is that
mammal mammalia which is another
technical term in biology no matter so
the you know the eponymous trait the
trait
for which mammals are named mammary
glands um
could disappear in some later mammal and
that some later mammal could lose fur
and could lose endothermic warm
bloodedness could lose all the things
that we associate with being mammalian
but it never ceases to be a mammal and
so you know my
you know when we're in phylogenetic
brain like you know is if the thing
changes its function it does not change
its
its fundamental identity as a part of
history which is what
mammal is whereas ligand is is not that
right so you have to be able to tune in
to both of these things
for their value and not ride them all
the way into the ground when you need to
switch to the other
way of defining things but just to make
as long as we're doing this i don't
think there's any way that we can avoid
my correction
for the full period of the podcast but
just to go
down the uh the road here a little bit
farther let's take ligand
in some contexts that are familiar to us
all right
we've got neurotransmitter right
neurotransmitter crosses a synaptic gap
very locally and triggers a receptor on
the other side
right you've got hormone which is
basically the same mechanism but it
transmits from one part of the body to
another part of the body
right pheromone will do the same thing
from one body to the next and then
you've got another category like so you
i don't know what you're arguing
what i'm arguing is that the category is
useful and interesting are you claiming
all those things are ligands i believe
so
well i guess we'll find out if i'm wrong
geez i don't why did you go there
i don't know i guess i have a a taste
for living on the edge
um but then there's this other category
entirely so in all the cases i just
named right
neurotransmitter uh hormone and
pheromone
you've got basically the receptor
and the ligand are both being generated
by the same
system right and you're pronouncing it
differently just because there's a
those are two alternative pronunciations
not because you're meaning to
use it in a different way now i have no
idea why i said live
i heard myself say it and thought i
wonder why i said that so
they're both used yeah actually we're
gonna come back to consciousness a
little later this was a case in which i
heard myself say something and it
suddenly caused me to be conscious of
all sorts of things that happen in
speech when you're not usually conscious
but
okay so you've got those three things
which i'm going to claim are all
ligands right triggering receptors and
then you've got a category where you've
got
like neurotransmitter mimics where
something like a mushroom
is creating a molecule that it does not
use internally nor does it signal other
mushrooms
with it of its species mushroom is the
wrong group but a
fungus is not signaling other fungi what
it's doing
is interfering with the physiology of
creatures that might eat it
right and so is that in the category
ligand does ligand have to be generated
by
members of your species that are trying
to hit that receptor or can it be gamed
by something outside and still be a
ligand
well this i mean this is this is exactly
why this word always
always drove me a bit nuts you know my
my
you know admittedly sort of you know
undergraduate level understanding having
learned from
you know one of the best repeatedly and
yet it just it never
quite fit for me would be uh
it's not within the species that created
it in this case because they don't have
a receptor
in which it can you know it has that
effect it's doing some different role
and this is a role-based definition
as opposed to an historical based
definition
i agree i agree but again the lesson for
you all what we would have said to our
students is that the key
is to extract the value out of out of a
definition without falling so much in
love with it that it blinds you to the
other thing and so both of these things
are
simultaneously in play yeah so anyway i
look forward to finding out if all those
things are considered
ligands by those who consider such
things i mean yes i
i kind of it's not that i mind but i
just don't care
like i just don't care whether or not
they fit into this category that feels
i mean you and i disagree a little bit
like this category just feels
a little bit too human-constructed to me
and if we're now playing around with
like well is this one is this one is
this one like
can't we define those things
independently of
whether or not they fit into some
additional human category
i i disagree because in the same way
that
i have argued that there are stories
which diagnose
journalism they diagnose particular
publishers
right a story will cause a publisher to
do something
right and diagnoses it this term
causes you to discover both the
natural category the gray area and so
um you know just in the same way that's
saying
that actually seals are bears
not the same way though because that's a
historical claim this is my point but
that's that's not what i'm i'm arguing
i'm arguing that there are certain
things that
cause the discovery of something
important and so
the fact that this category has a
troubling gray area at its edge
right does not mean that it doesn't
have a strongly positive cost-benefit
analysis at a net level that it's
really valuable to say there is
something that nature that biological
nature does which is
one part of something tries to talk to
another part of something and then if
you push this far enough you'll realize
that it isn't just
the something that's talking to itself
or members of a species talking other
members of the species it actually is
interspecies and that you know i i just
think
so many things are are defined i guess i
just
find playing around with edge cases when
it's about human semantics really
much less interesting than just about
any place we could be playing around
right but the alternative then
is either to draw a hard boundary
that has no gray area and blocks you
from discovering
something important right like enzyme
and
catalyst an enzyme is a catalyst but
catalyst is a broad category that really
falls apart when you get to enzyme
because enzyme is a machine a catalyst
is typically a very simple chemical now
you're gonna get in trouble
i love this argument yes but go for it
well i mean i just think it's
quite clear and actually this is one of
these places where
uh it was much harder to understand this
in the era that you and i first
encountered biology because there wasn't
such good animation of
what these things are like in reality
right and so the picture on the page of
this
highly complex protein folded up and you
know oh this is a catalyst and it
facilitates the reaction you know
between
these two um substrates
inherently static yeah it doesn't
capture it whereas if you see like the
uh the enzyme complex that uh does dna
replication and you're like that's
that's not even a machine that's like a
factory right that's a factory that's
taking
you know a raw material and you know
whiz-bang you know catalyst doesn't
evoke it at all so anyway yeah
all right we've done it all right now i
have to i have to do my correction well
i mean i
i'm i'm prepared to do it but you know
you want you want to start i have some
things to say about it of course you do
of course you do okay so here's
here's what it was in the last
discussion we were talking about
adaptive immunity which is this amazing
process by which your immune system
discovers the formula with which to
fight a pathogen and it's actually
evolution taking place at the cellular
level so that it happens on the same
time scale as your pathogens
right you have a little army of
effectively single-celled organisms that
have your genome and your interests
and they play this adaptive immunity
game to learn right
and heather hearing this uh of course
she knows about it but here in the
description of it says how far
back does this go and i said um i
told i said it was a risk to my
reputation to say what i thought the
answer was
that i thought i had looked into it
before which i'm sure i did
and that the answer i'd come up with was
that it goes back to our common ancestor
with salamanders which heather points
out
means that it would cover the group
tetrapods
and which is the first the original
vertebrates to come to land
right now it turns out i had that wrong
however that happened whether
the knowledge of how far back it
actually goes has changed since i look
it up or or i misremembered it
well but it was it was wrong if you were
going to be wrong one of two ways with
regard to an historical estimation you
were wrong in the correct way
it goes even farther back than you
thought it's not that it goes as far
back as you said
right it goes back as far as i said and
then
some and but the important thing so i
don't feel like this is just a flat
out correction because what i think what
i think people will have heard us
talk about is i said i believe it goes
back to our common ancestor with
salamanders and i said
but there's something that troubles me
about that which is what the hell do you
do with an animal like a shark how does
it not have
adaptive immunity when they can live
actually hundreds of years
right something is not adding up and so
there's a question and
in fact you explicitly raised the
question of whether it might be
vertebrates
which it turns out it is right so the
group that has this adaptive immunity is
vertebrates so it goes back considerably
farther than i had
suggested basically the aquatic fully
aquatic ancestors
of the terrestrial creatures that i had
thought or i had suggested was
was the answer and so anyway in this
case i think
a yes i was wrong but b you heard us
navigating in real time
as biologists might what the you know
we were testing whether the claim made
sense and we actually had the right
instinct even if if the answer was
incorrect which also demonstrates that
we don't have all of the facts that
we've ever known
on board at a moment's notice but we can
derive
um parts of what must be true and that's
that's that's part of
what we're doing in front of you guys
and um and i think a large part of what
the appeal is it certainly was when we
were in classrooms
um to to demonstrate for people
who are who are younger and learning how
it is that you would deduce things
um about the universe so i would just
say that we heard from a number of
people on various forums
um that it that it was older than
tetrapods but
um you know true to form one of our
one of our former students one of our
one of our best students
came to me with the most succinct and
clear explanation and i asked him if i
could just quote him he just texted me
this is jeff ladesh
writing off the top of his head he says
via text listening to your latest
podcast
i think all vertebrates have adaptive
immunity hagfish and lamprey have a
different cell lineage that are b and t
cell analogs but structurally different
so it's possible parallel evolution
and then i think all other vertebrates
do adaptive immunity via some kind of
bnt
cells i thank damani wrote back quickly
and quickly and briefly checking the
literature i can confirm that i'm
remembering correctly this abstract
captures it nicely
i'm going to show the paper to you guys
in a second and then he says
i originally learned this on one of your
programs while doing a deep dive into
vertebrate immune systems and i think
indeed
actually i was going to say that was one
of the programs with the molecular
biologist but no it was a different
vertebrate evolution
um but so the paper that jeff linked me
to
zach if you just showed this real quick
is a review
from 2011 on the evolution of adaptive
immunity and vertebrates and the thing
about adaptive immunity being about 500
million years old is that since 2011 it
hasn't changed much
but also our understanding hasn't
changed that much there's certainly been
advances but
um this is all true so i'm just going to
read the first sentence of the abstract
and the last two
which is exactly fitting with what
you've just said and what jeff reported
as well approximately 500 million years
ago
two types of recombinatorial adaptive
immune system arose in vertebrates
and then at the very end despite these
differences
in anticipatory receptor construction
the basic ais design featuring two
interactive t and b
lymphocyte arms apparently evolved in an
ancestor of jawed and jawless
vertebrates
within the context of pre-existing
innate immunity and has been maintained
since as a consequence of powerful and
enduring selection
most probably for pathogen defense
purposes so
very wild most that sounds very
conservative
probably for pathogen defense purposes
pathogens have an advantage they evolve
really quickly so we've developed a
subsystem that evolves on the same time
scale
like you know how amazing can facts be
it might be about pathogen defense it
could be arguably yeah all right so we
just drifted into an adaptive immune
system
dr you know that can't be um all right
so
are we there with respect to the
corrections i think so all right i think
we've done it and we'll see you next
week who knows
what massive corrections we may have to
engage oh fabulous yes
all right what's next on the agenda uh
the cdc recommending that essential
workers get the vaccine first to address
racial disparities they've been revealed
by the
should pandemic say that again yeah why
don't you um let's see first let's just
go to the wap the washington post
article um if you would show this sack
covet 19 is devastating communities of
color can vaccines counter racial
inequity
uh and that's there and okay that's
probably it that's all we need to see
for here
um actually zach would you put up the uh
i've got
screenshot of the new york times um
yeah here we go so this is from a piece
in the new york times that was published
on december 5th but updated december
15th so it's been reviewed
recently and it says
uh harold schmidt an expert in ethics
and health policy at the university of
pennsylvania
said that it is reasonable to put
essential workers ahead of older adults
given their risks and that they are
disproportionately minorities
older populations are whiter dr schmidt
said
society is structured in a way that
enables them to live longer
instead of giving additional health
benefits to those who all
who already had more of them we can
start to level the playing field a bit
so how many different ways is this wrong
it's pretty spectacular that we would be
playing this out i will say actually
it's a very fitting following on our
corrections i
i'm going to say i predicted this one
because i said
where is this all going it's going to go
to
reparations in every interaction
at every scale yeah 24 hours a day 7
days a week 365 days a year
and that's effectively what this is is
that people are being programmed such
that
any place where you could distribute
things differently based on race
it's assumed to be a good thing and it's
just
you know there there are a couple of
demographic markers
that everyone seems compelled to elevate
at every other cost at the moment
pushing that one slider all the way to
maximum thus
reducing outcomes minimizing the effects
on
of these decisions on outcomes for every
other possible category not just
within that category obviously it's
going to have health effects on
um older white adults but it also means
that there are going to be effects for
for everyone else hey we've got a
visitor for the first time in a while
visitor who very definitely has adaptive
immunity yes he does
um so i i don't exactly know where
you all are headed here i know there are
some things about this i
i am multitudes now yes i i believe we
all are but um
but anyway i think you've ever called me
you all before it was you all
two separate words so i don't i think
i'm on safe ground but
um go for it but in any case um
so to be clear the cdc and most of what
we know i think comes from a slide deck
in which
they presented this material and they go
through
an analysis it's not a super high
quality analysis but it's sort of
um you want to just show a little yeah
you want to show a little bit they do
their little matrix thing you want to
zac you want to i have it on my screen
zach
there we go yeah you want to scroll up
okay so this is coming out
by the way oh then we can't scroll
down please
all right so let's get down to there oh
so here they're basically arguing that
there are
uh three different categories competing
they're they're alluding to trade-offs i
think kind of
ham-fistedly but nonetheless they're
alluding to trade-offs but i would also
point out that this once again reminds
us
that um the sort of the hashtag slogans
that are accompanying the culture wars
um always pretend that there are no
trade-offs so you know the one that uh
you know that i've talked about most in
the past is hashtag believe all women
really all the time no matter what
they're saying under any circumstances
right
um and then another one is is it follow
the science
yeah like yeah something about like
always trust the science under under all
circumstances no matter what
and here we have well like no and like
this is not what they're doing they are
recognizing frankly that there are
tradeoffs
and that um and that they're they're
they're not
just going to follow the science at all
moments
um yes you want me to scroll down
somewhere yeah i do want you to scroll
down some more
i mean i i fully believe that actually
the science doesn't
you know it depends how you categorize
this right but um the science doesn't
answer the question what you should do
it can
if it's done right it can answer the
question of what is the case what are
the facts but then
the ethical part is distinct yeah but
okay under ethics they've got promote
justice by which of course they mean
promote social justice by which of
course they mean
capital s capital j 2020 brand social
justice which is about equity
and not about equality so let us be
really clear here
in some sense they are arguing
for race-based medical triage
right triage being the mechanism whereby
when you don't have the resources to
save everybody as in on a battlefield
situation
and prioritize um those who are uh
best able to make use of what efforts
you have and you may let people die who
could be saved
because uh you know it's it's a required
phenomenon the question is
race-based triage really that's how
we're gonna do this yeah
okay so okay now go ahead
i was i was gonna did you stop here for
a
reason
no i just have a couple more things to
say on the subject but but go for it now
go for it
um there are a couple of things
i'm gonna need my screen back here zach
um there are a couple of things
that this reminds me of um
and one of them is a word that we said
at the same moment when we were talking
about
this morning which is tuskegee like the
the tuskegee syphilis uh
study which started in what is it 1932
targeted black men and allowed black men
to die of syphilis even
long after treatment was known and
available even long after i think it was
penicillin
was understood to be treatment for it
um and you know in fact i went back and
looked at the new york times
which is uh you know quoting this um
this health expert saying that we should
not give the vaccine to older people
because they're
primarily white first the new york times
back in 97
and earlier also did a good job
explaining why
this tuskegee was appalling right
and everything in what the cdc is saying
in the slide deck now
is is not only race-based but presumes
that the vaccine is an unalloyed good
that there is
there is no question at all about
um sure efficacy but primarily safety
and if there is if there is anything to
the many concerns that have been raised
very few of which are saying
oh the mri the mrna vaccine is bad most
of what you're saying like we did last
week
we cannot know yet then what if
by actually doing race-based uh medicine
here
we are repeating something like what was
done in the early 20th century
and it's it's it's frankly completely
appalling
you know it's it's it's racist either
way
either way and just one more thing to
that end
because we don't know the long-term
effects of the vaccine
and because there is reason to think
that there might be long-term effects of
the vaccine
that is actually another reason to
prioritize
older people in getting the vaccine
not only because they are more likely to
have very bad outcomes from it
but because if there are very long-term
effects of the vaccine
they are less likely to be revealed in
those people
yeah um the the thing here
is this is an experiment
being run at a scale that um
is it fair to say that there has never
been uh at least medically speaking
it's going to be hard to come up with a
case in which
there was a broader scale experiment in
long-term consequences
maybe there is something but the the
degree to which
this is rapid deployment of something
novel that doesn't mirror anything we
have
experience with in the absence of any
mechanism that might tell us what the
long-term consequences are
this is an experiment being run at an
unprecedented scale and the idea
that based on race people are going to
be advanced in this
cannot help but imply
that at some level we are willing to run
that experiment
first on people because they've been
disadvantaged which
you know it's a gamble could it be that
being
high on the list of the vaccine ends up
working out for you of course it could
be this vaccine could be just as
promising let us hope
that everyone who receives the vaccine
uh gets a health boost from it
gets a healthy boost that's what
everybody are low
and that the long term you know i mean
there's lots not known here including
whether or not this has any positive
effect on transmission
right explicitly not known at all excuse
me explicitly not known so
provides may provide some immunity for
the person getting it but whether or not
if they have it
they're less likely to transmit it we
know nothing yeah um so anyway this is a
an argument that in this context i i
believe completely accidentally
amounts to running an experiment on
disadvantaged people that's their
argument
um you know by giving them the vaccine
first while we are
effectively lying to ourselves about how
much we know about how safe it is yeah
um so yes echoes of to ski indeed
um all right can you scroll further down
in there sure
you want zach to show it again yeah
would you show it
this no keep going keep going so they
have this matrix analysis
here science implementation ethics
they've got mysteries here and then
as you go through the slide deck they
fill these things in and they give
ranks and it's all very
pseudo-quantified
but uh keep going
it's gonna get people dizzy dude yes it
is why don't we do this off screen
i don't know what you're looking for
well i just wanted to show some of the
matrices
filled in yeah here they're uh it's a
different matrix
matrix there we go so they begin to fill
these things in and as they do it what
they
reason so this is their reasoning
whether true or not
is that prioritizing hold on for people
who are listening and not watching
it's a matrix of three columns three
rows science implementation and ethics
that same
diagram that shows up throughout and
then the columns are essential workers
non-health care about 87 million people
this is u.s
adults with high risk medical conditions
over 100 million
incidentally high-risk medical
conditions includes um obesity
and either former or current smoker
which is how that number is so big
and adults age over at 65 or over
years of age uh 53 million right
okay so the
result if you scroll down we got one
more another matrix there it is so
here's how they have uh
oh no nope this is a different matrix
well this is becoming confused but let's
just say the sum
total of what they did was determine
that they would save more
lives if they gave it to the elderly
um but yes the ethical implications as
the
as they read them suggest that there is
a reason
in spite of the fact that we would save
more lives if we gave them to the
elderly to prioritize
um essential workers first now
so there is you know as there is an
echo of tuskegee here there is an echo
of eugenics here
too right there is you know if if we
read
that you know in the 30s that there had
been a
you know a terrible flu in in germany or
in
europe and you know that the nazis had
decided to deny jews vaccines
right we'd understand it completely it
would fit perfectly with that story we
would understand it as what it was and
then in this case because everything's
on its head
you've got a um you know a kind of
nonsense that's sort of
superficially well these people are more
disadvantaged therefore
priority to the vaccine levels the
playing field even that language is kind
of
creepy um yeah i mean it is the same
language
of of you know old old-school racists
and specifically anti-semites look at
how much the jews have gotten in the
world and we just we need to take from
them what they have that isn't
rightfully theirs right advantages so
therefore i mean it's very much the same
language right so now
the at the bot i've done a lot of
thinking about this and the question is
is there
anything at all to what they're trying
to do
is there's some hint of reality under
this and i
i sort of think look if you made the
argument
that there are some neighborhoods for
example
that have been disproportionately hit
because for whatever reason
you know the way they get to work puts
them in danger people who
have been watching our live streams will
remember the subway
issue and the issue of local trains
versus express trains
right there are certain places you can
live that put you in danger and those
things
these you know whether you're in danger
based on where you live or where you
work is not evenly distributed by race
were they to say look we are going to
deploy these vaccines in the places
where they stand to do the most good and
that happens
to be racially biased i wouldn't have an
objection to it right
but the idea that you know you're going
to categorize
all of these essential workers right
okay so now you've prioritized essential
workers
over people who are even more
disadvantaged and don't have a job
you know from the same neighborhood why
did you do that right if you're really
trying to correct
a disadvantage with a vaccine which
doesn't make sense
right then the point is you've done it
so clumsily that it can't be defended
and you know we're it neighborhoods you
know where were we going to guess
that uh not only does immunity to the
disease
come from the vaccine but that uh
immunity to transmitting it also comes
from the vaccine and therefore we will
do
more good if we deploy it in a
neighborhood that has less control over
the spread of this thing because
people are packed densely together or
something like that you can make a
perfectly valid
uh bioethical argument for it but even
though there are a couple of logical
leaps there that aren't founded
yet just because no one has bothered to
figure out but they're not you know
you could imagine that the look i i
think
chances are that if we understand the
vaccines correctly in terms of what they
do
that they are also highly likely to
reduce transmission right
it's not certain i hope yeah well it's
not certain but the point is
you know there are reasons that you
could imagine that that would likely
fall
we just don't know yet so you could
build a policy
that would protect those who are most
likely you know protect
communities that are most likely to have
this thing spreading in an uncontrolled
fashion
and that would be racially biased but to
put race first in their analysis
you know this is this is the road to
hell yeah i agree
i agree anything else on this subject
um no i think we've i think we've pretty
much got it
okay um the next one i i've got i've got
something of a rant
all right okay um i have uh attentively
titled in my own head this section
jumping the shark with the new england
journal of medicine
so um new england journal of medicine
i'll just start with their tweet because
why not why not go there
new england journal of medicine said
here zack
sex designations on birth certificates
offer no clinical utility
and they can be harmful for intersex and
transgender people
moving such designations below the line
of demarcation would not compromise the
birth certificate's public health
function
but could avoid harm okay
they link in that tweet to their newly
published paper which is here
failed assignments rethinking sex
designations on birth certificates
uh here hold on a second let me go to
this is the paper
uh in a pdf form so okay
um the first paragraph of this paper
which was just published
three day uh two days ago failed
assignments rethinking sex designations
on birth certificates in 1900
the year the u.s census bureau created
the first iteration of the u.s birth
certificate
nearly all births occurred at home often
attended by family members and midwives
without specialized training
during the 20th century as the medical
profession assumed greater
responsibility for managing childbirth
and also assumed responsibility for
completing birth certificates
a process that includes a medical
evaluation to categorize each newborn as
male or female
we believe it is now time to update the
practice of designating sex on birth
certificates given the particularly
harmful effects
of such designations on intersex and
transgender
people so um
i am going to argue
that's failing to include sex on board
certificates and they do specify they
want to
move it below what is called the line of
demarcation which means that it is not
available
as a public part of your uh birth
certificate and it is still available as
like
aggregate data for statistical use but
it's not part of your
your id um
that in fact doing so
doing this will cause much greater harm
much greater confusion societally but
also much greater harm
mostly to women but also potentially to
men because so much of our medical
models
until recently have been based on
research on
men and have assumed that the male model
was the one that applied to everyone
and in fact we now know and i'll provide
a ridiculous amount of evidence here
um that men and women have different
outcomes different ideologies different
disease progressions for
so many conditions that if we start
pretending
at the level of birth that this is not
true we are going to
cause a tremendous amount of harm um
all in service of a p of okay so
intersex is real
and there is potentially some real harm
done
by the misassignment of uh sex
on someone on a on the birth certificate
of someone who is in fact
intersex uh and trans is a muddier issue
uh but uh we will we will get back to
that so i want to read two more
paragraphs from this paper and respond
respond to them one paragraph
designating sex as male or female on
birth certificates suggests that sex is
simple and binary when biologically it
is not
sex is a function of multiple biologic
processes with many resultant
combinations
about one in five thousand people have
intersex variations
as many as one in a hundred people
exhibit chimerism mosaicism
or micromosaicism conditions in which a
person's cells may contain varying sex
chromosomes
often unbeknownst to them the biologic
processes responsible for sex are
incompletely defined and there is no
universally accepted test for
determining sex
wow that is so many numbers like i'm
super impressed with them aren't you
they used a lot of numbers
but like i got a few numbers too i got
some numbers
so we have been sexually reproducing
with two and only two sexes
uninterrupted for 500 million years
that's a conservative estimate you're
not talking about you and me you're
back to vertebrates that's like adaptive
immunity and sex
for sure have been in our lineage for
500 million years
uninterrupted but that's conservative
probably
sex with two and only two sexes goes
back one to two
billion years in our lineage to the
so-called lika
the last eukaryotic common ancestor
that's an acronym l-e-c-a
and maybe that's 1.2 billion maybe
that's as far back as 2 billion
but we're talking billions that's a lot
of zeros for you guys who are using all
these numbers and clearly don't know
what they mean
also we do have a universal way of
defining sex actually
apparently you haven't been thinking
very clearly about this it's called
gametes okay if you produce or could
or will or do or might have the
uh or have the machinery to produce
gametes that are tiny and zippy
you're male and if you produce or could
or will or do or have the machinery with
which to maybe or
will in the future or did in the past
produce gametes that are big
full of cytoplasm and stay still or
sessile you're female
simple right but that didn't have very
many numbers in it so it's not very
sciency is it
if it doesn't have numbers it's not
sciency so here's a couple more numbers
sex ratios return to one to one they do
there's a lot of math behind that i'm
not going to go there now but that means
with all due respect and recognition as
i already did
for the existence of intersex people and
who are very very very rare
and the also incredibly rare truly trans
people
roughly half of any population at any
moment is male and roughly half of any
population at any moment is
female sex differences manifest
in many places because as i already said
these most of most of what we have known
until recently about medical
processes and treatments have been done
on men if you start confusing
men with women and vice versa and don't
let it be clear what you're going to
have is a whole lot of downstream health
effects
mostly cascading to women's health so
here are just a few let me pull these up
so here's the article you can just show
my screen throughout this sect
we have this article published in 2020
by the prestigious
new england journal of medicine here's a
2008 paper reviewing the sex differences
in alzheimer's disease not just
in progression but in etiology just in
in
in symptomology and how it presents here
is
a 2017 paper on sex differences in the
epidemiology clinical features and
pathos
physiology of migraine here's a 2000
here's a 2002 paper on the biological
basis of sex differences in
drug abuse here is a
let's see when is this where's the year
on this um
you can't find it 2013 a 2013 paper
on the sex differences in parkinson's
here's one from 2003 on sexual
dimorphism and asymmetries
in the gray white composition of the
human cerebrum that's brain differences
like actual anatomical physical brain
differences between men and women
and here's one on the text emphasis is
fascinating
on the structural connectome of the
human brain that is to say the ways in
which the neurons are intersecting
connecting
so um there are no differences [ __ ]
this is ridiculous and like i cannot
believe
what is happening i cannot believe it i
was reading this paper and i said to you
i feel like
society has jumped the shark this is
completely insane okay one more
quotation yeah yeah one more question
from these people
assigning sex at birth also doesn't
capture the diversity of people's
experiences
about six in a thousand people identify
as transgender meaning their gender
identity doesn't match the sex they were
assigned at birth
others are non-binary meaning they don't
exclusively identify as a man or a woman
or gender non-conforming meaning their
behavior or appearance doesn't align
with social
expectations for their assigned sex
again i'm like
so impressed with them aren't you so
impressed
babies have really amazingly diverse
experiences in utero don't they
and then of course the ones that they're
later gonna have all of that has to be
captured on the sex on the birth
certificate
i'm wondering too about those other
people who identify as different species
like the other kin
like they identify as elves or sea
snakes or something well in order to be
respectful
and fully inclusive of the other kin i
feel like
we should put sea snake on their birth
certificate oh wait
actually we're doing something else
we're just taking human off of all of
our birth certificates we're now not
going to assume species
because some people are delusional and
think they're not human
that's not how this is supposed to work
what the hell is going on
well what the hell is going on first of
all i am
shocked to discover that birth
certificates do not capture the
whole experience that people have in
life i mean i know
they're defective documents clearly
totally shocked here's what i think is
actually going on
i think that there is actually a
central argument that can't be won and
must be won
for the trans activists to succeed right
so
you're talking about the trans rights
activists not the
different slightly overlapping
population of people who are actually
trans
right right exactly okay i think the
argument that
has to be won is that science
is supportive of their
position that there is no distinction
between
a woman who arises at womanhood through
regular developmental processes and one
who arises
there through transition okay so in
order to get there
they have to attack the sex is binary
and basically say science has concluded
otherwise right
and they are muscling
things like the new england journal of
medicine which we're going to return in
a later episode to
the corruption of science journals and
things but what you're effectively
seeing here
is that a corrupted science journal is
willing to go along with this nonsense
that anybody associated with this
journal should know better than
most of them will not understand that
the the game is not chromosomes that it
is in fact gametes but nonetheless well
it could be corruption and it could be a
form of don't work
don't hurt me that's the same thing it's
so but
no i think i mean corruption corruption
is an umbrella category yes so there can
be multiple kinds of corruption and one
of them can be motivated by fear and
just like what i was calling the don't
hurt me walls that
that had all the black lives matter
stuff on them during the summer
um in storefronts lest they be
vandalized
this is kind of a don't hurt me article
okay any new england journal medicine
is playing by your rules please don't
come after us when we pull you something
that maybe you don't like
right um i mean corruption in the sense
of that file is corrupted
right there are many forces that distort
what you might find in the science
journal some of them you know you could
find outright
bribery you can find many things that
are shy of outright bribery but function
like it you can find
canonical ways in which it becomes
confused but the point is what you're
reading in there isn't what it seems to
be
because it's been corrupted by some
force and here i want to try to draw out
the argument okay
the argument is you will find in many of
the things that we are fighting over
that you never imagined we would have
arguments about there's a basic process
which is there are two
polls having an argument and what they
do
is they stamp out the space of nuance
in between right so you and i are trying
to hash out an argument that is in the
space of nuance in between
we do not deny that there are trans
people we do not deny that they have the
right to be treated as they would ask to
be treated for most intents and purposes
we do not believe that that should
extend to places where there's an
objective fact that requires
that you obscure it in order to do it so
this is a
or you put half the population at risk
by doing so right
we do not believe that you should assume
that you know
children who flirt with the idea that
they might prefer to be the other sex
actually are and all of these things so
anyway there's this inter
there's this space between these two
arguments
and the trans rights activists are
stamping it
out because the argument that sits there
is look intersex is real and it is
a physically measurable and studyable
phenomenon
trans is real and it's not the same
thing as intersex it may have some
relationship to it but there's lots of
trans stuff that doesn't come down
to physiological intersexness what's
more
it appears to be ancient and widespread
many cultures have a version of trans
right
and so there is something in which you
can say look
trans is natural and to the extent that
there's any sort of
oppressive tendency to pretend it
doesn't exist or is
a you know is necessarily about
something being broken
that's a bad argument however
trans is natural right it exists at some
level in many
populations maybe all of them what isn't
natural
is availing yourself of pharmaceuticals
and surgery and these other techniques
should you be allowed to i don't know
probably but we do get to decide
right if you decide that you want to you
know have your arm removed and attached
to your ear
i don't think we let you do it right so
the point is it's not that you're
entitled to any modification of your
body you want
so to the extent that there is something
to be modified then there's a question
about whether or not it is supported
by the science and so in order to win
that argument
they have to pretend that in fact
science invalidates
the binariness of sex and we all know it
that's the pretense
right science invalidates the binariness
and so they are going after this and
you know it's a silly hill for them to
die on because
you know no here let's let's see
let's say that we we played their game
yeah right and we just said you know
what
sex isn't real sorry we blew it uh we're
taking it off the birth certificates
we're gonna just assume everybody is
uh is a blank until they tell us what
they are right
in that world some of them are sea
snakes
more power to them um uh
sn sea snakes by the crate all right oh
nice
nobody's gonna get it yeah but that's
those are the ones i like to give the
most points to oh
yeah i feel good about that um so i've
now
lost my place and that's my fault um
but uh here while you're coming up oh do
you get it
well let's get us back there but well so
uh
i'm reminded that this is actually the
one year anniversary of jk rowling's
um descent into this into this craziness
in which she stands
up for for reality she says dress
however you this is on twitter dress
however you please
call yourself whatever you like sleep
with any consenting adult who have you
live your best life and peace and
security but force women out of their
jobs for stating that sex is real
hashtag i stand with maya hashtag this
is not a drill that's maya forstatter
um who was forced out of her job um for
insisting that actually sex is real okay
i got my place back excellent good so
let's say that we obliterate sex we
decide it's not real
right and we take the trans activists at
their word that they're as
on board with science as anybody and the
science just doesn't support a sexual
binary
and so they're pro-science anti-sexual
binary because science supports them
right
so we move forward into the world we
obliterate all references to sex that
are not self-defined
right and we embrace science okay
science is going to rediscover the
awkward fact of sex
again and again and again because it's
so
very reliable right in other words in a
world where there was no sex
some bright graduate student is going to
come up with the idea
you know i wonder if um
somebody having a penis at birth is
predictive of the content of their cells
at any level i wonder if it's predictive
of their likelihood of getting
alzheimer's late in life i wonder if
it's
you know predictive of some feature of
parkinson's disease
so the point is you cannot get around
the fact
that of you know you can have a lot
noisier correlations than
you know than sex and still have a valid
pattern worth describing right
sex is so low noise with respect to how
much variation
there is with respect to the basics that
it would be impossible not to
constantly be rediscovering it if you
just simply blindly point science at
interesting patterns everywhere
right you'll find sex like many times a
week
so so anyway i think the point is look
that was something like point sex at any
pattern and you'll find sex many times a
week
no sorry point science at any pattern uh
blindly at any pattern and you'll find
sex many times a week many times a week
you'll keep rediscovering yeah so
anyway i think the point is look they've
just they've chosen a hill to die on
that doesn't even exist
right either the point welcome to
post-modernity that's
it right either the science is
real and functions in the way we know
science does fallible but basically you
march in the direction of knowing more
over time
right in which case trans is natural
surgical alteration and puberty blockers
aren't
there's an incredibly strong tendency
having nothing to do with any
anyone you know designating somebody's
sex at birth
in which boys tend to grow up into men
and girls tend to grow up into women
right this is just this is the way
things typically function
it's not god i thought it was god
gotten a lot of ranting out here but i
think the point is look there's no hill
there
either well against science like i said
this is the nature of postmodernity it's
like okay there's this there's this
hill that the scientists that the
scientists are standing firm or standing
on going like
sex is real hello sex is real it's
literally perhaps over a billion years
old i mean sex is over billion years old
but it may be over a billion years old
in our lineage alone
um and they are over here in flatland
or in a depression going like that's not
a hill those aren't hills
we're on a hill like we got the hill we
got the hill and the hill just happens
to agree with our idiosyncratic and
self-incompatible set of beliefs yeah
and oh by the way totally delusional
yeah
all right well good that was fun that
was fun
journalism time man oh journalism time
okay so now
wow boy really got to switch uh
headspace for this one yeah what i
wanted to do
is lay out a thought and it it treads
near some thoughts that are
you know talked about it treads near
what eric has called audience capture
but i don't think it's the same thing
okay um so
what this is is a thought about why
it is that we find ourselves in a space
with um mind-numbing
fake news that caters
to our preconceptions rather than
informs us
and the idea is this the idea is we
commonly i think
believe wrongly that people want to hear
stuff that they already believe that
they basically have an insatiable desire
to be told the same things that they
already believe and you know there's
some desire for this but
the question is is that really true are
people so
interested in hearing what they already
believe that they will
avoid hearing things that they don't
already
believe that challenge their their uh
system of thought
and i'm not so sure about this in fact i
think you know it has been
remarked on by many including us but
there's something interesting about the
fact that a population that we were told
had a very short attention span
and basically needed to be catered to
with three camera sitcoms
actually you know regularly tunes into
you know
joe rogan marathon podcast with all
kinds of
interesting experts and you know is
willing to dive deep in these things
that
the same people are willing to you know
follow game of thrones season after
season with these you know
these over layered plot lines people
actually have more of a taste for
complexity
than we tend to give them credit for
it's very easy to oversimplify
people's tastes and what i wanted to
point to
is the question of whether or not
advertising
is actually the thing that causes the
mind-numbing
default to a dichotomy between two
stupid narratives and the idea is the
idea is this
and this goes back to what you and i
people who are familiar with the podcast
will have heard us talk about
consciousness
and the point is that consciousness is
a mechanism it's not a good way of doing
things if you're super awesome at
something whether it's playing the
violin or
um you know skiing or tennis or anything
you're playing when you're flowing
you're not it's not the conscious mind
playing the game it's when you become
conscious that you choke
right and so the idea is that
consciousness is there for a very good
reason
it's an adaptive process but it's a
spectator for anything you're really
um good at right and it comes into play
once you're good at it yes once you're
good at it so you learn something
consciously and you're very bad at it as
you're learning because you're
sometimes you learn things consciously
yes many things are conscious
my favorite example here is ping pong
actually and the reason i like ping pong
is that the game is so fast that when
you're playing good ping pong
you can realize you can't possibly be
playing
consciously because you're just not you
couldn't do it fast enough right
you know so your conscious mind is
present right it's watching the game
but the point is you know i'm surprised
i got that
whatever so can i interrupt just a
moment to say that um
we've referred uh in the past to playing
pool uh we've now put the ping pong top
on our pool table and last night we are
playing ping pong on both us
and with our younger son toby and i
benefited
from your introduction of a totally new
cocktail last week and so had a couple
of portland mug shots
in advance of playing ping pong and uh
it uh it interfered somewhat with my
with my unconscious with your
unconscious ability to
to return the ball yeah all right well i
apologize
there's still probably net net it's
worth it but um but yeah it's not good
for your ping pong game um
all right so the idea is the conscious
mind is there
to deal with stuff you don't know how to
field in other words your conscious mind
comes online
when you're confronted with something
that you didn't expect right
if if you go up against a a an opponent
in ping pong
and they keep delivering the ball
somewhere where you're not anticipating
it your conscious mind will think well
are they putting a kind of spin on it
that i don't know or
just simply it will notice that the
pattern is that they deliver it to this
corner more frequently than i think they
will
and so i'm going to cover that corner
better right you have that conscious
thought
so the connection to the question of
journalism
is advertising
that is not strictly speaking
informative and i would say
a lot of advertising contains some
information about a product but in
general
it functions on bases that are not
conscious in other words there's no
reason in the world
that the attractive model sitting in the
passenger seat
of the fancy car should persuade you to
think differently about how good a car
it is
or even if she comes with the car that's
the thing is they never do yeah
so um you should not have your
sense of value of that car or your need
for it or anything else altered by the
fact that the company who's selling the
car has hired somebody attractive and
put them in the seat of the car and if
anything you should think
um well the car is going to be somewhat
more expensive because they're investing
in persuading me on a sexual channel
that i need this machine right so
the point is we know that this works
because advertising is well studied
and people pay billions of dollars you
know in the aggregate to be selling all
kinds of things
they're basically persuading you of
things on unconscious channels
so here's the question if you link
advertising to journalism
right journalism that does get your
attention
but wakes up your conscious mind because
it challenges what you think
may not be very good match for
advertising
right you may not be so persuaded by the
attractive model in the car
if you're in your conscious mind because
your conscious mind is smarter than that
right and so the question is is there an
evolutionary tendency
as we have used advertising to
fuel journalism and you know this has
always been there there's always been a
kind of hegemony of
the advertisers over the content of the
newspaper and that's always been a
problem
but at the moment so much of our world
is being driven
by advertising appended to everything
that
anything that properly tunes in to
lulling people into that sense of calm
that makes them i mean just even think
about the way the internet works
right advertisers are paying based on
clicks that means they're paying based
on how effective their ads were so any
ad that was depending on persuading you
of something on an emotional channel
that is unconscious
is going to discover when it works that
you click more
what if it's true that journalism that
wakes people up and causes them to think
oh
geez i didn't realize that right what if
that kind of journalism causes people to
click
less on the emotional ads that are
spread around the page
and so it goes extinct yes you know or
it gets driven to sub stack or whatever
happens to it
and then the point is the mainstream
just becomes
a reflection of your your biases and
your predispositions because that puts
you in a buying mode
right that's the point is is it the
advertising it's not that
we wouldn't read the stuff that would
challenge us and make us smarter
it's that that doesn't work from the
point of view of the economics of
the journalistic establishments that's
excellent and it's i mean it's a really
different model than the one um that
anyone who's thought deeply about
advertising
how it's how it has affected content in
the past has looked so i'm thinking
specifically i mean
just because it's something i did
research on a long long time ago
i know particularly how advertisers
have been able to at least in the past
specifically
um drive content in so-called women's
literature women's magazines and
actually decide
not just what page you know what what
so-called editorial comment
content is opposite their ad but also
what that content says
which means you know makes the entire
magazine effectively an advertisement
there is nothing that is ad free content
in a magazine even when you're reading
something that is supposedly you know a
feature or something
and that is um that is a model that is
you know heinous and has been much
decried in all of this and it's also
really easy to understand
right like you can you can just you can
get there without thinking very hard
about it
and you can wonder if it's still
happening and you can suspect that
there's some covert stuff
um but it's just like that's a model
that is encapsulated
within that story this is different it's
a little harder to grok you gotta you
gotta sort of spend some time with
um with what the implications are and
why it would be evolving this way and
why it might not have been noticed
by those who would be trying to be
paying attention to the metrics in the
first place
yeah um and you know i wonder uh it's
the kind of thing that might be worth
talking to gad sad about
his yeah i was just thinking this is
exactly his expertise yeah um
but uh anyway i think it's an
interesting question there are a lot of
places it goes
unfortunately i don't have the tweet
something came up in a discussion that i
was um
party to and it reminded me of a
hypothesis i advanced many years ago
95 i believe so there was a tweet
that somebody was showing in a
conversation that i'm part of
and the tweet argued that porn
is actually because it's male biased
because it's targeted at men and it
sexualizes women in a particular way
it is actually causing women to imagine
that they
are lesbian even though they prefer
having sex with in the company
of men in romantic context
so what i advanced in 95
was not about porn at all because of
course porn was
you know it's existed you know it's just
hills
but it wasn't accessible and as
ubiquitous and normalized and all of
that stuff
as it is now and so anyway my nearby
hypothesis
was that in fact it wasn't porn but that
it was
advertising because males are so driven
by female sexuality
right the advertisers have honed in on
it right
sex sells and typically that means um
you know the male version of it
right because it makes men impulsive and
and all of that
so the the hypothesis that i advanced
was that
um that basically women
were being sold as sex was being used to
sell
products right that in inadvertently
the male view of sex was being sold to
everybody including women and that women
were in fact finding themselves
um you know lustful towards other women
because basically
you know irresistibly desirable images
of women were being you know
constantly broadcasted everybody so i
don't know whether this is right or
wrong
yeah and it's consistent whether the
porn has greatly amplified
some parallel thing but this was also
some place
that would be worth paying attention to
indeed
all right is that it that's it for my
perspective
all right um our final
segment we wanted to talk a little bit
about what time of year we're in
and um and reliable dickens as well
so we are i think the solstice um is
going to be on the 21st
it's always a day or two it is solstice
eve eve
it is solstice eve solstice all right
right now
yes um so uh here in the northern
hemisphere where most people
watching and listening are are living in
the shortest day of the year
it's definitely feeling like like winter
is coming
and boy is there widespread fatigue
and just exhaustion with with everything
that's going on
and um you know hanukkah has always
been around this time of year but it was
sort of a minor holiday
um christmas i actually don't know the
history
um and you know in in my natal home
growing up it was always a time of
of of great joy and and wonder and
lights
and family and community and all of this
and
um the fact that there is no historical
evidence that jesus was born anywhere
near the winter solstice the northern
winter solstice and in fact i think
there may be some evidence that he was
quite
quite precisely not um suggests that um
moving a
major holiday for one of the major
world's religions
to a moment um exactly as pagan rituals
that might
actually honor things like the solstice
astronomical realities
were being downplayed would help people
at a time when things are literally
getting dark when astronomically things
are at their darkest and things are
about to get even colder
and even though the shortest day of the
years and two short days from
when we are talking the day length
changes
are very slow right now they're you know
we're not going to really start seeing
a significant uptick in day length for
you know several more weeks
after the solstice so all of that
all of that suggests that regardless of
what you think about
there being a sky god or not that there
is value in ritual and there is value
specifically
in in being around
around festivity and light and that is
all but impossible this year for many
people uh
that the the combination of the actual
virus
and the societal response to it has
meant that
uh the vast majority of people at least
in the us
are effectively or actually um again in
lockdown
and it means that you know many many
people have actually not had a normal
interaction with another human being
for you know the better part of a year
and it's it's tragic
and you know may we maybe we have a much
better one of these next year but also
um everyone can get through this like we
we can all get through this
and i know it's really hard
you're looking at me like you have
something well i just the somber tone
you're taking is going to make it
impossible to make fun of this holiday
okay go for it and then i'll read
dickens who doesn't no no
i would never i would never of course
you do
well i just look the thing is
christmas is really um a much
it's the it's it's about faith clearly
at a very very original level yeah no i
mean in more modern times
um because
you're giving me that look no look it's
one thing
it's gonna be about reindeer isn't it oh
no reindeer come on that's a myth
um yeah no look it's one thing to have
faith that they're the universe of
300 sixtillion stars
was created by somebody intentionally
right and that all of this is part of
some plan it's one thing to have that
level of faith a lot of people do and
have for
millennia it's another thing entirely to
have faith
that you can cut a tree off its roots
and bring it indoors and it's going to
be all right and then all right as if
jesus thinks it's going to be all right
it is pretty
and it smells good and it's enjoyable
it's weird
you're a bad person it's true
but the whole thing was set in motion by
a you know a radical rabbi as i think of
him
so anyway well i don't i don't think the
trees were i think i think many of the
parts of the christmas traditions that i
like the most are actually borrowed from
the
the pagan traditions that pre-existed
them
yeah i mean i agree and i do think it's
a solstice holiday and that you know
it's actually um we will at some point i
think we have not talked about the
the uh odd fact of the calendar not
being an integer number of days and
therefore
there being an incredibly hilarious
history of people trying to figure out
how many days are there in a year and
getting it wrong and bad things
happening
yeah um but anyway there is reason to
have
god's meanest joke well i
this is the wrong season for me to be
saying this right in between hanukkah
and
christmas but i think that this is the
proof that one of two things has to be
true
right either this universe was not
created by a god
or he hates us because
if it was created by a loving god it
would be an integer number of days
right and it would be a lot easier to
know when to plant your crops and all of
the important things that
go with that but by making it tough you
have to deduce it anyway and then you'd
have a stable answer
and right exactly and so this is this is
either god's joke on us or
uh he's uh absent he was at least absent
in the creation phase of the uh
universe am i in trouble now i don't
know why i'd be in big trouble
all right let's let's go dickens all
right let's do it
um okay so it turns out we don't own a
physical copy of a christmas carol so
um there's a great site um what's it
called uh so i'm gonna read this from a
printout that i got but um
gutenberg.org has put publicly available
versions of many of the classics online
so even if you don't own a particular
book you can find them
their entirety this is from a christmas
carol first published in 1843 written of
course by charles dickens
which is and this is a play that we saw
um was it last year the year before
we've seen it recently
um yeah and we saw it locally yeah we
saw it we saw it recently in
in portland with my mom this is the
first christmas
aside from when we were in mexico a
couple of years ago
i think that we have not been with my
mom
since our children were born so that's
um
that is a sadness here we go
the door of scrooge's counting house was
open that he might keep his eye upon his
clerk
who in a dismal little cell beyond a
sort of tank was copying letters
scrooge had a very small fire but the
clerk's fire was so very much smaller
that it looked like one coal
but he couldn't replenish it for scrooge
kept the coal box in his own room and so
surely as the clerk came in with a
shovel
the master predicted that it would be
necessary for them to part
wherefore the clerk put on his white
comforter and tried to warm himself with
the candle
in which effort not being a man of a
strong imagination
he failed a merry christmas uncle god
save you quite a cheerful voice
it was the voice of scrooge's nephew who
came upon him so quickly that this was
the first intimation he had of his
approach
ba said scrooge humbug he had so heated
himself with rapid walking in the fog
and frost
this nephew of scrooges that he was all
in a glow his face was ready and
handsome his eyes sparkle and his breath
smoked again
christmas a humbug uncle said scrooge's
nephew you don't mean that i am sure
i do said scrooge merry christmas what
right have you to be married what reason
of you to be married you're poor enough
come then return the nephew gayley what
right of you to be dismal what reason of
you to be morose you're rich enough
scrooge having no better answer ready on
the spur of the moment said ba
again and followed it up with humbug
don't be cross uncle said the nephew
what else can i be
return the uncle when i live in such a
world of fools as this
merry christmas out upon merry christmas
what's christmas time to you but a time
for paying bills without money
a time for finding yourself a year older
but not an hour richer a time for
balancing your books and having every
item in them through a round dozen of
months presented dead against you
if i could work my will said scrooge
indently every idiot who goes about with
merry christmas on his lips should be
boiled with his own pudding
and buried with a steak a holly through
his heart he should
uncle pleaded the nephew nephew returned
to uncle sternly keep christmas in your
own way and let me keep it in mind
keep it repeated scrooge's nephew but
you don't keep it
let me leave it alone then said scrooge
much good may it do to you much good it
has ever done you
there are many things from which i might
have derived good by which i have not
profited i dare say
return the nephew christmas among the
rest but i am sure i have always thought
of christmas time when it has come
around apart from the veneration do its
sacred name and origin if anything
belonging to it can be apart from that
as a good time a kind forgiving
charitable and pleasant time
the only time i know of in the long
calendar of the year when men and women
seem by one consent to open their shut
up hearts freely
and to think of people below them as if
they really were fellow passengers to
the grave
and not another race of creatures bound
on other journeys and therefore uncle
though it has never put a scrap of gold
or silver in my pocket
i believe that it has done me good and
it will do me good
and i say god bless it
nice yeah it does um yeah it does raise
exactly the question that you began with
with respect to this being a
uniquely isolating christmas
it is and uh yeah maybe
we will figure out what to do about that
in other words there are
um hints of us developing new ways of
interacting with each other
that uh do not replace you know being
physically together but nonetheless are
better than
staring at your tv um so anyway maybe
yeah just leave that as a as a tease for
now well i
just think um you know maybe
it's the darkest well as you point out
the days are about to start getting
longer even though it's going to
continue to get colder
and maybe it will be a winter of
innovation
oh let us hope yep let us help
all right um so we have the
usual announcements that we'll make here
and
then we'll be back we will take about a
15-minute break and be back to answer
your question
so uh if you have questions ask them via
super chat
um on this hour or the next
you can if you wanted for instance to
have a portland mug shot
go to www.store.darkhorsepodcast.org
it's also on the screen here
and although it's um i don't even know
if it's
totally too late to get anything by
christmas at this point you can use the
code
you can use the code christmas all caps
to get 10 off through christmas on
anything you order
um patreons of ours get a little bit
further discount
um darkhorse.moderator gmail.com
is an email account that you can use for
logistical questions
like when would the private q a be if
you join heather's patreon for instance
and how do i pose a question at my
patreon we have a private q a every
month a two-hour q a that has few enough
people that we can engage with people in
real time on the chat
and actually just before our live stream
today i opened up um
for people at the 11 up level uh the
forum to
pose questions for this month's q a we
don't get through all of them
but we prioritize those um asking
questions at that level and up so that's
open right now
you have uh conversations at your
patreon every month for people at the
higher
higher tiers yes and i should probably
make an announcement about that
so in the last iteration on the saturday
conversation the coalition of the
reasonable conversation
there was a hiccup it was my fault that
i didn't catch it
in patreon and certain number of people
did not get their invite so we are going
to reschedule that conversation and we
are going to open it up to anybody
in that group who wants to be a
participant so if you didn't get your
invite send us
a uh an email at the darkhorse.moderator
gmail.com
darkhorse.moderator will do it
if you sign up uh before we reschedule
which would be at least a week out
um you can be part of that conversation
i think it's exactly one week out i
think it's going to be
on boxing day oh that's right right okay
so that does mean that if you signed up
um for your patreon that's the 100
level um you would be usually your
conversations are the first saturday and
sunday of every month so there's going
to be a second one this month
right there's gonna be a second one this
month and you could get in on it and
then you'd have another one
uh soon thereafter yep very soon very
soon thereafter so
anyway there's that and anything else um
yep you get access to the discord server
at either of our patreons at the 5
and up level and we got a great clips
channel thank you david for
doing this with really some terrific
things coming out all the time
indeed yeah and uh we'll see you in 15
minutes see you in 15.
be well
you